i actually have a few london tactics
that maybe we can just start as warm-ups
just
to loosen up a little bit and then we
can kind of dive into
the more specific variations
awesome that sounds like a plan
is the london your favorite opening for
white eric
london yeah as white it's
it's an opening i learned like
maybe six or seven years ago and then
once i learned it i just fell in love
with it
finally someone who understands me
from a very like pure
like chess principle point of view
you're you're developing the bishop
outside the pawn chain you're making
both bishops happy from very early on
uh and the pieces find like a lot of
harmony and that's why it's like one of
the most popular openings chad among
beginners
take notes chat but uh even like even at
our level and beyond like even like
top super gm's magnus carlsen
are using london to
just completely destroy the competition
and there's so many tricky mines
yeah i try to study their games but it's
always like really novel ideas and then
i forget about them but i've been trying
to
diversify my london repertoire
nice well that's good to hear because
you can never stop learning like even
though it seems like london it's just a
basic setup there's so many layers to
keep peeling away and
uh
like especially with the move order and
yeah if you're
ever peeling onion just just be careful
not to cry too much
yeah it's okay i never shed tears when
playing the london system maybe just on
the other end
yeah
well okay so the positioning we have is
i know a line that we cover and maybe
in one of our last lessons right
with takes takes knight t2
yep and yeah i'm sure maybe this looks a
little bit familiar which actually
um i did have a question about because
what happens is they don't take the pawn
they play bishop e7 and it's actually a
lot more annoying for me to play i
remember we talked about the e4 idea
which this is actually a good recap
um okay so i want you
so this is actually just a warm-up
tactic
um is after bishop takes c5 is white to
move thanks ben fine for donating
oh shout out to ben
all right sorry i'm focused now no
worries
um so
it's white to move
and
uh this is more like a tactical exercise
we did do i should i should i remember
we did this last time and we trapped the
queen
what's that right
uh bish no no no not the bishop
um well it's tricky okay i have to think
i remember there was an idea see the
hard thing we when i get taught i
do more memorizing than like logical
thinking so now i immediately remember
like oh there's ideas with e4 or bishop
e5 but the queen does escape to a5
so it doesn't seem like it's so
important to not just rely on like
memory because sometimes
uh memory can deceive you and it's
important to just understand kind of the
tactical
elements in the position like what are
the targets how can you
effectively attack them
yeah i need to that's what happened with
my hammerless and i did more memorizing
um i also see the pressure on
okay then i'm just gonna assess this
like without trying to remember
background knowledge obviously the queen
is nearly trapped there's an escape
square we do have a pin which is why i
looked a little bit towards like 95 but
the problem is they can defend pretty
easily with the bishop
um
maybe we could attack this bishop but
like
no i really like the fact you're
highlighting all the targets like the
knight the bishop the queen they're all
potentially exploitable there's one more
target that you sh you have to identify
in this position
okay
i mean isn't this just winning a piece
yeah just winning the rook oh i just you
once your knowledge g7
bishop b5 you're you hit the queen
you're not trapping the queen because
there's five but you you win the rook we
win more which is yes just completely
winning so the reason i wanted to show
you this one specifically was
you had this position against hans
neiman
are you serious playing a game for a
date video
and you didn't play visit e5
i was testing you to see if you if you
learn your lesson i did not learn my
lesson oh my god i remember that act
because he was like oh you just missed
the win you pointed out right afterwards
right yep and i still forgot it so see
this is how you know
i'm not i need to be thinking more of
the sometimes it takes a few times like
seeing the same tactic for things to
sink in and i didn't mean to embarrass
you but it's uh you did it's the case
you did sorry about that but sometimes
embarrassment is a way to effectively
learn oh yeah now i will gen i will
never forget this line which is great
so
there's an important nuance with the
move order because
normally you won't get this position
and normally black has a knight already
developed
to
f6
so like hans played a small wrinkle
where he delayed knight f6 and that
allowed for this bishop e5 idea that
normally you won't get um
in like the main main lines but that's
why you always have to be tactically
aware and the spot moves like this
the main line is with knight f6 so yeah
if we if we review like the main line is
knight f6
it is
way more common
and then i like that this is called
crusher gm and eight moves because i
could have literally crushed the gm and
eight moves with that you had the
position as white too wow
just really upsetting
okay all right i'm gonna put it behind
me i'm listening
but it's incredible like how many traps
there are in the london that grand
masters will fall into
that i think yeah it happens to me like
on a regular basis online
so
do you know the move for white in this
position because move order is really
important
um
i think i feel like it's it's knight d2
yeah we covered this in our previous
lesson like nine 11 months ago or
something yep you don't want to go c3
first you want to go knight first you
want to give the rook breathing room
because after queen b6
this is where you go into what looks
like a very similar line is takes
yes and then the main line is rook to b1
and i don't know how much i want to like
go deeply into this because there's a
lot of
complexities but as long as you know
rook b1 and then bishop b5
yeah i would just ask you about the
bishop e7 line because i think the main
line is taking on c5 um but
and that one's easier for me to study
but it's bishop b7 that a lot of players
have been doing
right so and as far as i know uh okay
after e6 white castles
yep and bishop b7 is the most played
move at like the top oh okay
um maybe
okay
maybe bishop c5 it's playable
um
but after bishop e7 this is where you
play like the stockfish alpha zero
novelty
and like it's a relatively new one
it's not e4
it is oh
okay okay
it looks like e4 isn't playable because
there's two attackers
and one defender but the resources are
just incredible for whites in this
position i only remember this because we
did this last time but i
still need to understand the move
properly yeah yeah
yeah the way to understand this is
you're trying
white's trying to like disturb black's
development basically like black black's
king is still in the center so you're
trying to create enough tactics and
initiative uh to prevent black from
completing development
and it turns out it's bad for black to
take the pawn
uh oh is it does bishop b5 fork at the
end
because
there's actually a really incredible
move here this is a line where you trap
the queen
we didn't do this too okay we did look
at this but i i would be impressed if
you remember it because the move looks
completely
i think i know it i think i have it uh
knight c4 ic4 yeah
yeah you just give away your knight
and the point is you have
a rook b3 and you trap the queen
oh not bishop
so bishop e5 yeah bishop e5 looks like a
traps the queen
um the problem with this move is it
allows queen takes e4
and then after takes takes black has
three pieces for the queen
got it so rook b3
more effectively material
i'm really glad we're reviewing this
actually okay this is good yeah yeah
like once in a while like the more you
review this
um
hopefully the more it'll like stick in
memory and then as long as you kind of
understand the main ideas too
hopefully you'd be in a position to like
figure it out during a game
so then can we also take a quick look at
bishop take c5 because i may have gotten
mixed up because i think it was the main
line
so maybe it was bishop takes c5 that i
was struggling but i think i also
honestly forgot to play that trap in
real life in online games against bishop
p7
yeah so when the bishop comes to c5 um
this is actually where
going back to your game with hans you
can employ this resource
bishop to
e5 and got it and it's multi-purpose
you're not winning g7 but you're having
ideas of just damaging the structure
and okay the queen has to move here or
here
queen a5 looks natural
and then then probably simplices just
take on f6
and the rocket is now making it supposed
to go
yeah that's okay that's pretty simple
makes sense
and whenever the queen has removed
itself from c3
one of the most thematic breaks in the
position for white is c4
where you you try and just get rid of
blacks d5 pawn you uh
if takes you you can activate your
knights you also have ideas later of
knight b3 and putting more pressure on
everything i was going to ask is knight
b3 like we want to trade that night for
that dark squared bishop right
so yeah it's a very uh
very likely to be a major threat and you
couldn't play knight b3 right away
because it would hang the bishop so c4
also defends your bishop so you're
preparing okay
yeah this this is very logical and i
i've seen not even this line but
um i think
it might be in some of the joe bava
positions um where we end up taking job
of london i've been trying to play that
where we take on c5 um and they also
have c4 ideas which sometimes i struggle
with because once black has too much of
the center i don't really know how to
play those open positions
um which maybe we could look at one of
those later but yeah it would be helpful
to see an example but um yeah
for this line specifically it's uh
it's good to know of this pawn break and
even if like if the queen takes on c5
then usually whenever you get the chance
you want to play c4
because it's a way to make progress and
just maximize pressure against black
okay and let's say they just played
normally like let's say they played
bishop e7 here
yeah bishop e7 is a fine move and the
position is is still chaotic because
you're down upon
uh but you have some nice initiative and
uh
i think the the continuation would be
still knight b3
you can kick around the queen
okay the queen's gonna be a target and
also knight on c6 so
there's queen
queen here here
uh we could look at queen
my main question and this is kind of
thanksgiving for um other similar
positions is when to know if you're
supposed to remove the pressure in the
center i mean obviously right now you
can't because your bishop would be
hanging or if we're just supposed to
leave it but let's say like after the
castle the rook might be coming here
like i always take right away and then
maybe go for like some knight d4 stuff
or maybe knight d4 and then take but
yeah yeah i was curious how you would
play that
so the point here is you're you're
making threats
in such a way that you're you're
preventing black from castling so if
black gets in castle and rook d8 and
then you're on the defensive then
something has already probably gone
wrong
um i think the the point here is you're
you're improving your knight with tempo
on the queen
and regardless if if the queen moves a3
or b6 you're gonna again improve the
knight with tempo
like let's say queen b6 you play knight
d4
and here you're
you're pressuring c6 and again black
camp castle because you're
you're ready to take unleashing the rook
yeah there's so many ways you can
generate yeah
interesting okay
no this makes a lot of sense i don't
think i've i've definitely been
misplaying this line because i don't get
in these positions and i play the first
like
seven moves correctly well
it takes a lot of accuracy and sometimes
like if you're playing a lot of blitz
and bullets you don't necessarily have
the time to really slow down and
gradually consider your options
um but like if you're playing a longer
game it it's it's very pleasant to play
this as white because you have a lot of
like attractive looking ways to put the
pressure on black
awesome okay this is perfect this is a
great recap of this main line
yeah and i think like
one way to kind of organize your london
preparation
is just knowing
like knowing this position uh after
knight bd2 because this is one of the
main
um
there's a word called tabia i know if
you've heard this word tabia before
um it's like a tavia position it's like
it's one of the mainline positions where
things can branch out
and uh like black has a lot of options
we just looked at queen music's but
there's there's a lot of different moves
for black
yeah
actually this is perfect this is
literally what i wanted to look at like
so bishop f5 and bishop g4 is what i
wanted to look at yeah i know
yeah i've been looking at your like your
recent games in the london and i've seen
you you've reached this position
uh several dozen times
yes and
you've encountered bishop f5 a good
amount
which i i think you're supposed to take
on c5 yeah i i didn't see you play this
move online but you you yeah i
that's the thing like i keep studying
this position because i keep getting in
this playing it regularly and then hey
because i it's boring and it's
symmetrical and i know like here and i
know that we can somehow um actually all
right let me see if see if i can
understand it um yeah so it's very
important to play the next move yes for
white because lock's ready to take and
be happy
yes i'm trying to think if it's either
knight p3
or it might be something else
um i know
okay now i'm getting the i'm pretty sure
i like the fact that you pointed out
knight b3 because it's good to
understand why knight b3
is not the best move
because it looks like you're just
defending the pawn but black black has a
nifty uh nifty approach is just to take
the pawn
and then yeah after takes queen a5 yeah
yeah yeah yeah um which yeah this is
confusing me because in one of the draba
lines we actually let them go for that
fork and there's a way that we can
defend against it and i was just
thinking about that position right now
um there's a different resource here
rather than directly defending the pawn
you can create
yeah you can create other threats knight
d4 is uh is a really nice move
because you're
you're hitting the bishop and you're
pressuring the knight like one major
threat is bishop b5 here
yeah okay
yeah see
yeah understanding i know like i've
memorized this line but i struggle with
the ideas and the concepts behind this
position yeah so like going back after
uh after black played bishop five the
reason for taking is you're preparing
this move to exploit the bishop
got it and it's really worth remembering
or like understanding too because
i can't tell you how many strong players
have just walked into this against me as
black and a lot of players will play
bishop g6
is trying to like hold their ground but
then white has bishop b5
and again
like with initiative yes it's just
crushing
white's winning material here as far as
i know um most people will play rook c8
oh okay i know how this wins because
then we take sorry we take and we fork
yeah just to show for for chat um
takes bishop basics or rook gets trapped
okay there's bishop b7
and
and what if they defend with queen c8
yeah queen c8 then
black is kind of subjecting themselves
to passivity
and they still haven't won back the pawn
and now you can just defend the pawn
with b4 oh okay this is very convenient
um c3 is necessary bring your knight in
e5 is impossible because you take so
everything's under control for white
here
this is this is a great review this is
good
yeah so especially i think we're
covering the at least some of the lines
that you'll encounter most often so you
know yeah for sure
um one more thing if if knight d4 the
best move for black is to take the pawn
but then you're very happy to snag the
bishop here oh this is the position yeah
this is a similar position i don't know
if c4 is an idea here maybe not because
i have this but like when i just don't
have the pawn on d4 i really struggle
playing these positions
yeah so here there's there's no reason
to be like too confrontational as white
you can just calmly complete development
bishop d3
improve the bishop attack the pawn
black will probably play g6 to defend
and yeah you probably don't want to play
c4 because it allows d4 and yeah the
thing to understand here is black has an
isolated d-pawn
so
whenever the opponent has an isolated
pawn
one of the most important squares to
control
is a square right in front of the pawn
so i'm assuming knight b3 is that i move
like knight b3 or like to start with
even
oh just ensuring nothing like the pawn
can advance
and once you you blockade the pawn then
it's going to be a long-term weakness
eventually
um i usually like to put the queen on f3
rook on d1 castle
and white has a really nice setup and
the bishop pair and better structure so
yeah this is very useful like i this c3
move is another move i memorized just
because i'm like oh in london you always
push c33 but i when i studied it i don't
actually look at why am i doing it which
you should yeah if you understand the
threat of d4 this is very logical
yeah yeah there's understanding like the
immediate like threats but then there's
understanding like the
the optimal like best setup and if you
you know like where your pieces will be
with the knight coming to b3 brook's
coming to the d file then
uh then hopefully you'll be happier
entering these positions
great i need to just actually start
playing these lines in games
yeah yeah and like
again as maybe some of this will still
be a bit
new or fresh and like if you play a game
and you didn't remember your preparation
it's really important to go back and see
what you can do
even when you play hans
yes i can't believe i i could have won
that match with a beautiful london line
that would have been such a big win for
the london
especially
winning and eight moves basically
yeah that would have been i could have
made two videos could have made me to gm
and eight moves and i could have made
the date video
great youtube content
next time
okay so we covered bishop f5 um
bishop g4 bishop g4 i i remember i
showed you in one of our previous
lessons
okay let's recap
i'll give you another like tactical trap
this is one of my favorite london traps
okay i couldn't have forgotten if it was
your favorite and it starts very simply
just c3 completing the the london
triangle
uh black will play e6
and then
the the move i like to play is
not the main line like most gm's play
queen b3
oh i forgot about this yes because i
keep playing queen b3 because i
understand as soon as the bishop pins
you you want to get your queen out this
is always like the most common move but
yeah you play this move which i did
forget about there's nothing wrong with
queen b3 but queen a4 like it'll it'll
trap a lot of
even strong players because the most
natural black is a blunder here
oh i was going to say queen c8 but
that's not natural yeah queen c is
probably
one of the better moves but uh
wait to move here
there's one winning move
and the funny part is we've done this
before and i forgot it
okay try and address like what are the
potential targets whether light's
resources
okay
um so
we have a few threats
like knight in the center which would
put pressure here and here but then
we'll look into them taking which
not sure if that leads to anything
there's bishop here we do have some
pressure on this pawn which we could
take we could have some attacks on the
queen
um
so oh well if we trade first and then we
go knight here then we're attacking this
bishop and we're attacking this so well
the bishop is defended so we actually
don't have as much time as i thought for
bishop b5
um bang
what if we played this first attacking
this because then he has to defend with
the queen and then the queen would waste
a tempo when we take here so i think
and if he takes if he takes our bishop
then we could take check so that's fine
so i feel like it's bishop here because
queen here then we play here then he
plays here then we play
here
but even that's not that good that's not
actually winning because then you can
depend on the rook and sure we have a
much better position yeah so you've
identified
like almost all of the main
attacking resources for whites
the
the common mistake that you've made here
and it's easy to make in a lot of
different types of positions where
there's like a clear best tactical
continuation you're going down the wrong
rabbit hole
and there's one idea
one move in particular
that you just didn't consider like you
you drew the arrows for like all the
kind of all the direct forcing moves
yeah but there's one other move that you
you kind of have to think out of the box
because it's
at first it just looks dumb and not
playable
trick it's bishop a6 oh my gosh i
remember this so vividly you showed me
this i was so
so proud of this i played it for like
two weeks straight and then it just
completely slipped my memory and i never
played it again and forgot about it
yeah that's okay that's okay but like
that's why we're like review is good and
like hopefully
hopefully like someday you'll get this
in the game and then it'll never slip
your memory no this is a very important
reminder because what happens with the
london because it's the only opening
that i play for white which whether
maybe that's unhealthy or not um i
forget to look for new ideas because i
just i'm so used to all the basic themes
which is knight in the center maybe pin
here maybe bishop trades that i never
really start thinking out of the box
because it just becomes like all
instinct yeah yeah like if if you start
like
trying to explore and find new ideas it
can make just a position way more
exciting and it can make
your games more fun too because then
you'll you'll be having more fresh
positions rather than kind of the the
same old same old every game
um yes and just to explain like the
reason why this works is we hit the pawn
and we just want to take the pawn like
if if uh rook b8 we take and then take
this is great
i remember this all these lines forget
it and if takes we take and hit
everything and
yeah super fun position so if you want
to review this further
our last london lesson it's on youtube
you can re-watch the video
okay i will i i i yes i will do that
cool i will and chat you guys hold me
accountable if you see these lines on
the games and you don't see me playing
the best move then make sure to give me
the finger
all right
um what about and if they played queen
c8 in that position
oh yeah so uh yeah we can just
go
we forgot but i'm really i'm really
grateful for your patience and i'm also
really happy that we're reviewing
because these are such good lines and
yeah i played them for a little bit
remembered our lesson then just forgot
and never reviewed which i actually did
some london studying so i should have
went back to those
yeah it's sometimes like sometimes you
just have to shift the mindset to that
um like you're gonna review your lines
you're gonna like with every game you
play you'll you'll
see what you could have improved on
um yeah queen c8 this is where you can
basically unleash all the the arrows
that you were drawing earlier like this
knight e5 idea bishop e5
um because of course fish basics doesn't
work but you have uh i'd probably start
with 95.
and you're the pure
yeah you're hitting the bishop if the
bishop moves back then you can
just increase pressure now you have
three attackers against the knights but
yeah now we're just winning a pawn and
looks like white's just been on here
easy okay
okay got it
so hopefully that covers like we've
covered
the two main bishop moves
so if you ever
have like an otb game and your opponent
touches their light square bishop you'll
automatically like be confident
to this moment no this is very helpful
even though it's review this is very
important this is like literally the
stuff that i have been struggling with
in most of my recent games so maybe we
could play like a couple blitz games
where you do stuff that we've never
discussed before like your favorite
london counter attacks or something
yeah i'm curious maybe how you would
you would play against my
uh against my like auntie london as
black and then
see where that goes
so yeah if you want to play a game
video i don't know if you have one like
how to defeat the london but i know
you're known for traps and gambits which
probably aren't all against
would i don't know if it would all still
be the london but i want to see your
your best weapons against london well i
have one really dirty weapon
okay which i'm actually curious if
you've seen before
it's better to just show me
i'm gonna we'll play it out in the
analysis board because i don't want to
play a full game with this
but i want you to play as white
okay sounds good
all right i'm gonna be black
okay let's see it
oh no i hate uh ben did some of this
funny business actually i'm feeling like
it's this stuff where you're trying to
go for like this
um which i actually don't have a counter
attack but i just don't think it's good
okay you you've passed the test um
knight of three fine move
the thing to know
is don't play e3
yeah e3 loses a piece by force
oh i've definitely fallen for this ah
i'm trying to think block to move and
win the bishop
yep there's something silly with the
pawns and it always gets me
oh i think it's like
you go for this
wait but if i take with the bishop and
then you attack i come here
oh that's yeah that's it so basically
black will control all these squares
with the inside pawns i've fallen for
this a few times
yeah as long as you play knife three or
you can be safe and play h3 and give
your bishop room
but uh this is a really nifty one that a
lot of players will fall into because a
lot of people like either pre-move e3 or
they they play e3 without thinking
yeah and not surprisingly and like not
even for maybe it is because they're
hoping for the trap and then we play
into like a normal position which i
think we even had kind of a game like
today with ben
um
maybe maybe it wasn't this stuff but he
definitely did have some h5 pushes
um which i don't know if there's like
any main lines against this but
like this setup um and i try not to
allow this by just unpinning i think if
you just play normally as white it's not
something to worry about it but i don't
know if there's any specific lines i
would say just play normally like the
the thing to understand black kind of
wasted a tempo and opening like moved
upon hoping for a trap but they're
they're not really improving anything
with h5
um if you want to be a bit more
ambitious you can play a queen's gambit
setup
uh let's imagine like this and then
i even know what black does like
knight f6 you could uh
now you can play e3 because you're
controlling e5 with the knights
and uh eventually play c4 knight c3
is a bit more active even if they go for
a bishop g well here yeah bishop g4 you
have h3 so okay
it's weird some positions with bishop g4
like h3 is not a good move i mean of
course when the bishop still has the
square
um but even sometimes when they take on
f3 i feel like my queen is misplaced
uh yeah you you in general you'd be
happy with the trade because um
the way you can think of it your queen
is activating for free and black lost
two tempe just to trade off the bishop
and you got the bishop here so a lot of
reasons to be happy with bishop g4
bishop exactly
okay sometimes your queen can even come
to g3 and create the battery so i wonder
i want to see if i can remember this joe
baba position do you play the job of
london a lot
against certain move orders
okay yes um
uh let me see if i can remember how it
goes
um here g6 knight c3 or
not g6 lines um so d5 is it even
uh let me think d5 knight c3
it's oh yeah okay
um
d5 this is job right knight c3 on move
okay and now they go here and you have
to do this
aha this is it okay
and
um
okay this and now we're supposed to take
and they do this right
yeah
this is the theory you might be able to
teach me something here because i have
not studied these lines for either color
okay i was gonna ask you a question
about it so um
the one thing though like if if they
play this move order
uh-huh one of the key ideas when you
play job of london is knight b5
yeah which is in cases where it's not
effective but in this position it's
really nice
oh wait maybe it was uh
cause
maybe i messed up the move order then
if you can play knight b5 and black has
to respond with knight a6
you get a situation where
it's really hard for black to remove the
knight because there's no a6 the knight
is constantly tied down to defending c7
and you can get a setup with c3 a4
and your knight is really well supported
this is exactly what i've studied
this is exactly what i studied but there
is
i'm trying to think then what is the
line we're supposed to take because i
know pretty much you do knife b5 against
nearly everything well no here you have
to do e3 but here if they don't do any
c5 it's always 95.
i i'm trying to hmm
no i
i feel like okay i'm very curious if
it's knight b5 still in this position so
it's important like next time you
encounter something like this in the
game
that you realize you
you haven't like been prepared for or
you forget your preparation then you
gotta make note of it and
maybe it's see okay i think it might be
a i think what it is i think
d takes e5 is just slightly better well
i don't know so because on the on the
eval bar dtx5 is just a little bit
better than 95 so it might just be
theory maybe not maybe it is or maybe
both are playable at some point
now both look playable actually wait it
might be
oh i was going to say if they played
knight c6
uh so if knight c6 then uh white's
already winning yeah yeah yeah there's
no knight a6 and okay actually i need to
do more research on my lines before i
show you so never mind okay i think both
are playable but there was a very
specific
maybe my book just said to take there
but you could also do 95 but i actually
do have a question of that whole line
that we looked into since we pulled up
the job
um i was really proud of this let's say
like what's the most common g6 or
d6 in this case probably e6
six and then we go
um
we can either do this or this
well i'll just put in a couple moves
sure
it was funny because i thought this was
fantastic
and then i should oh it's because i
don't know that you could take care but
i'm gonna turn off eval because it's
it's
directing my train of thoughtlessness to
this um when do they get this night
somehow it's weird in this position i
didn't get this but i showed this to
hammer and what happened is they
attacked my knight which i think i
misplayed this for black because my
knight is not going to move in this
position and like you're supposed to
reroute to c2 and then hammer was like
well then how is this a better london
because your knight is just actually
worse placed
and i was like yeah that's a good
question
um which might so i think i'm playing i
don't know if you know the the main the
joke about that
it's up to black to solve some of the
problems
um i'm realizing here
you might be able to just start throwing
punches with queen a4
yeah okay yeah this is you're
threatening some deadly double checks
and then if
if queen d7 which looks very normal just
neutralize diagonal
then knight f3 and knight e5 is coming
there's not a great way to stop it
yeah so i think i'm not supposed to play
normally what if they did like 97 turned
off my d7 is a better move but this
should already be like a nice opening
success because the knights are like
this knight is sidelined this might have
to move twice to pass the square
uh okay you have knight d6 i don't know
if you want to play it so soon but just
develop and uh yeah maybe start applying
pressure but you should definitely be
conserving these moves
okay this is interesting yeah i think
what happened is i would play it as a
normal london but this queen a4 move i
haven't looked at so i'm glad you
brought this up it's a good resource if
you can combine like queen a4 with an
iconic e5
perfect okay that's all i needed for the
job cool all right some some three oh
games perhaps one yeah yeah i'm down for
that um all right if you want to send me
a challenge or i can send you a
challenge
okay all right i'm gonna
mute put on my techno tunes and really
try to focus okay go for it i'll mute
myself too uh just like i'm gonna try to
beat you just wanna get one win
okay okay good luck
all right sounds good i'll start the
game right after sounds good
and now it's time for
okay time for anti-london
so i'm gonna first go into the move
order that we reviewed this like bishop
f4
and uh
just make sure she's playing the right
move order
i'm gonna play a line that we haven't
looked at yet
is knight c6 and after knight d2 is to
take the pawn
so it's a small detail a small deviation
and with this move order black uh avoids
a line where white takes and plays
knight d4 so it's a different position
i'm just curious how she'll handle this
yeah c3 is a
very fine move
and while i'm playing right now is like
my serious
london tournament preparation
as far as i know bishop b5 it's not the
main line like queen b3 is the main line
oh
interesting
i mean she's being uh very ambitious
here like trying to destroy me right
from the gecko like when a four of us
may be interesting
i have three okay let's castle
i'm playing a line that has a very solid
reputation and as long as black can
survive like moves out the opening then
the hope is that uh
i can just get a more like positional
strategic game
a3 very fine move
i was considering this but then there's
knight c6
happening in that
maybe playable
or maybe not
probably not
q7 which is
i think the queen is better placed on c7
getting more
tension
and if
so now if a6
are we playing 3-0 we're playing 3-0
but it's unrated so she can't farm me
uh i think i'll play a6
because earlier she had knight c6
hitting my queen but uh
here
we trade i got the bishop here
and i i strengthened the center a little
bit so now the plan is to play c5
i'll try and show the
superiority of the two bishops here
while blundering upon
oh no my pong
i probably should have played a5 first
oh
interesting
i'll take with queen
i'm still offering a pawn
hmm
he actually played this uh quite
cleverly look at this
oh no wait things are about to get
really messy
higgs takes a knight d7
and then everything's hanging
okay that was kind of scary
let's go back to c7 i'm download pawn
but okay there's
there's still some issues for white
because now i'm turning f6
i have f6 no f6 the previous move there
is knight d3
yeah so we can call this a battery pin
the knight is pinned by the battery
knight d3 doesn't help because
there's only one defender
i'm not sure how white
deals with this threat
ben feingold's favorite move
ah
now if sex there's knight d3
bishop c5
on here
dirty flag me
i'm still down the pawn
but i like the compensation
i want to play bishop t5 eventually
thankfully i'm i'm up on time
uh
i go pond grabbing let's play this idea
this and this
e3 is a bit tender
hey connect four
lights e3 incoming
hey
botezz gambit
oh no my queen
oh yes my queen
okay
gg
she played really well
i almost got you there yeah i think you
you outplayed me in the early mental
game
i was destroying you with the london
until that
but it was i was gonna blunder under
time pressure anyway i can't explain
things happen
b3 was just a bad move but i was
panicking because you were playing fast
but i was only down four seconds that
was like a really good game there was
like a crazy tactical move that
i'm not sure what i would have done if
you played it
are you still in the analysis board
uh
oh shoot oh no it says you are oh no i
tried to do you have the pgn that we
made today or no
i tried
i didn't save it in time if not i'll
i'll make it oh i just loaded it in well
you can always re-watch the vod
yeah i just don't have the patience for
that but i'll do that
okay i'll go back man that was such a
good game
yeah
i'm an analysis i think
yep you went for you went for my throat
in the middle game or in the the opening
basically like
yeah i was
i mean actually i was glad that you
played this um
i think when they just played bishop e7
or not even bishop b7 like when they do
take on d4 sometimes and it's obviously
hard because you don't have this bishop
b3 anymore so you have to go for this i
do sometimes struggle with these but not
it worked out for me in this game but
not always
yeah so in this move order i was
actually going to show you this uh
earlier but it's good that we got to
actually play a game in it because if
you want to be
extra aggressive
the move that i can recommend
immediately
is not c3 but immediately bishop to b5
because you you save a tempo like not
moving your c pawn yeah and you can get
95 in and move sooner
and if bish if queen here
so and yeah one of the points is if
queen b6
you have uh you have to move c4
and this is a way more aggressive
approach where look at this i've never
seen this before it resembles more of a
queen's gambit
um
it can get really complicated because
okay d4 looks hanging black can also
take
and yeah don't lose your bishop but you
have to move a4
now the point is you're ready to
recapture with the knights
and that is this is a very nice smooth
order yeah from white's perspective it's
it's actually really pleasant to play
because
black has some issues to solve
yeah okay that makes a lot of sense yeah
so bishop e5 just um
just delaying c3 and actually i saw you
had a game
the one game i found where you played
this move was against kurt schneider
my god i should have showed you this he
like before a match he went and prepped
and he was determined to defeat my
london and he found a move that like
computer-wise wasn't the best move but
to find the refutation was so hard for a
human and he just destroyed me it was
like a two three hour match and i played
the same line every game and he kept
playing the same dirty lines every time
and he literally crushed my london with
it
yeah i'm not sure if i have the game i
mean i could pull it up um but i
honestly think if i look at it
let me know i was going to show you the
main deviation you should have played
yeah yeah yeah show me uh because i i
think you played like c3 or castling
but
the move because you reach this position
and the move to play is knight e5 right
away
yeah
which i don't know why i wouldn't have
done that this makes that's what i was
looking at right now
yeah so this is the same position that
we had but we had the inclusion of c3
and rook c8
and the difference here is that if i
play rook c8 which uh
is
it's actually a blunder
um because
say my same trap it's the same tactical
motif yeah yes knight c6
nice good stuff
um okay so yeah black already has to be
like really careful and yeah the main
line here is queen b6
and this is where you go for the same
idea c4
dc4 you you defend the bishop human back
upon
awesome okay this is very helpful next
time i rematch kurt we'll play this i'm
glad i'm glad you played this because i
struggle with these lines i can just
never remember because the games are
just
so many london games yeah well we're
looking at london from a very like kind
of high level perspective where it's not
just knowing the basic setup it's about
reacting to what black is doing this is
great awesome
okay um so maybe real quick i'll just
share the move i was scared of during
our game
is
yeah like we both kind of got a solid
position and then
i
realized my a pawn was just hanging
i was really happy when i realized like
because if i would have taken you now
you could have won c4 but i was pretty
happy with the takes line
yeah taking i think is is nice uh
is like nicely accurate oh maybe i had
like a fork oh no not here though
so you take check okay i was scared of
the the potential for knife seven so i
was kind of scared of rook takes e4
i was just looking at that yeah but i
think your attack on knight f3 rook
takes we fork
you move the queen let's say here
because it gets really messy because the
rook is hit and the bishop is hit
oof oh yeah that's a free queen you
wouldn't go there no no
need to go there oh interesting
i've actually i've toggled on engine
analysis just to get okay i'm not gonna
look i wanna look and see if i can
figure it out so it takes
takes so we've given an exchange
now we're up a night now
we are
down wait we've equalized
we've equalized here um we
got a knight and a rook and we gave a
knight in a rook so yeah now we've
equalized but our knight is hanging oh
this looks really good yeah because then
you take and you're attacking the queen
um but
let's say the queen moves here and isn't
our night trapped
but we can't actually take the night but
i feel like our night is trapped
my guess is this is winning for white
rook takes
is it so yeah so the the thing to keep
in mind you're already up
it's not the move
it's not but no it is it's um
it's not completely winning but it's one
of the the best moves
um oh yeah it didn't work because it
basically simplifies everything
like if i take with bishop
97 and
it leads to just a ton of trades
this is nice queen c6 you can take
cake
and then
oh there's some weird lines actually
apparently you can get away with this
how does this work though yeah we don't
need to look at this computer bs
not my brain this is actually really
insane but uh
what
queen
so
yeah because after rook d8 you can
calmly just move your bishop back and
then after rook d7 you fork fork oh my
goodness it's so hard to calculate that
fully
yeah that's insane but um
yeah i was
i was pleased you didn't go into it
because it looked terrifying
i was scared i was just like sure you
didn't accidentally give me a pawn so i
was saying very defensive because i was
like someone 2600 wouldn't just wander
upon here
yeah yeah but like white subject will be
better here i i tried to play it off as
a gambit and eventually worked out you
convinced me well sometimes you have to
call your opponent's block
exactly okay
that was fun let's do one more is there
anything else yeah one more would be fun
yeah i have another like line in mind to
test you with so awesome and rematch
okay good luck oh no how what if i play
like one move and resume i can just
draw do
rematch uh this should be it i can also
just on okay i'll just let's play one
more and then draw because it's unrated
oh wait isn't it better to a board raw
if we import it's not switching the
color though oh oh i thought you were
just having fun or something
i just didn't want to keep the morning
so you wanted to there we go there we go
okay all right good luck
uh what was i gonna play
oh yeah
i'm gonna play this one
it's funny to see the uh
just facial expression reactions
um
yeah let's see how she handles the main
line
[Music]
um there's a few different ways to play
this for black
i think i'll just play main lines
she goes into
the thing i want to show is this uh this
queen g4 idea which she could have
played in this position
this is really cool or takes first and
then queen g4
um but we're going into
[Music]
the main main line
oh bishop e5
usually plays knight d2 first i think
it's going to transpose though
yeah wow so i play this as white
failing what to play here
i know bishop e7 is like one of the best
moves
97 is usually not a move to play
wg3
i'll test around 97.
it's not a great move
because white has
what is it
oh yeah white has bishop d3 b6 and then
e4
wow
this is a new move for me
i think i'll play this
hit the bishop and
i'm ready to trade
yeah one of the points of 97 was to
leave the bishop staring into empty
space
and it would have been
a bit more precise for white to move
back
to the center
um now yeah it's already a little bit
difficult for white uh
like white either has to admit the
mistake and
lose true tempe with the bishop or trade
which also loses time
um i'm not sure if i can like easily
punish this
thinking b6
e694 there's also a queen c7
and eventually e5
between c7
we might end up trading but uh the point
is to prepare e5
ooh
c4 looks enticing
drop the bishop
five
i think i'll play e5
in the event that we trade everything
um
yeah a lot of pieces will come off the
board but it looks like a nice
positional transformation for black
this
light will lose a d4 pawn
and black will have a slight space
advantage
in the meantime i've also now opened up
the bishop
[Music]
h4 is interesting
usually like if the lights on g6h4 is a
bit more justified but
i think white's now regretting that h3
is not playable
pawns can't move backwards
oh hello to
sazanka i'll turn off some only mode
sometimes during a session like this
it's hard to
interact with chat
i hope for those watching hope hopefully
there's a
good takeaway lessons
or
playrook d8
okay just improving
oh i'm about to win on time
let's try and checkmate before i
can win on time
no mercy here
e4 looks really nice
uh
or
to do
here
oh no my queen
i'm gonna win on time though
wow she's unleashing lots of moves
don't hurt me
i miss the tactic
ricky seven oh no her queen
oh it's scary
and she went full okay
a lot went wrong there um if i would
have had some more time i would have
demolished you however yeah you went
full beast mode
i i panicked really i panicked a lot in
the opening that was not theory at all
but these i've just been enjoying these
games honestly
oh they're fun games yeah this opening i
think you maybe confuse yourself a
little bit i did i was like i was trying
you know like when your dad have you
ever been at a chess tournament it's
like your dad's hovering behind you
watching your games and like you want to
impress them that's kind of what i did
because i remembered this famous game
where bishop h4 was played definitely
not this position and it was like a
really great move and i was like ah i'm
going to play this great london
game and woo my coach and it was just a
terrible move just too much pressure
yeah there's cases where bishop h4 is a
great move but there's also cases where
it should not be played
here you end up losing time i was also
playing bishop e5 which typically i'll
just play 92 bishop b3 but i was also
like i'm gonna try to woo my coach
because i know the top players sometimes
play bishop b5 and the most i'll
probably learn from this since i don't
actually know how to play it
yeah i i was uh i was actually happy to
see bishop b5 because this is one of my
favorite lines to play for white
and you're in the analysis board right
uh
um yes now i am yeah i'm pretty sure
we covered this in our first london
lesson or our second one so it was about
a year ago
i asked you about this queen c7 line you
played this which yeah we did this is a
famous this has this also rings a bell
magnus carlson had this position as
white
yeah and he played a brilliant game
that actually uh a few days ago i played
title tuesday i had the exact same game
up until like move 18. is it it's not
that crazy game where like the queen's
here and like the knights here
um
that's a different one yeah i mean
there's a lot of like really nice
carlson games in london
um he played a game where his opponent
played knight e7
yeah and the move to play here and the
whole thing to understand
uh is usually
like the main line in london is with the
bishop on d3
in this position
wait wasn't it okay sorry you're gonna
you're you should explain the concepts
but was it bishop takes queen takes pawn
takes no
damn it okay all right that's a little
bit different
usually your bishop is on d3 rather than
b5
yeah so if black plays knight e7
you can play bishop d3 here and it's
like an improved
mainline london because the night is a
business place
we did do we did study this yeah and
yeah
b6 is the most common move
this is what carlson's uh carlson played
grand master business strong
god he studied this position from our
game so many times because you get into
like that interesting kind of middle
game where it's like you trade off the
queens
well and it's like there's a difference
because you have a tempo
but it's honestly just initiative like
white
starting with e4 every single move from
white is either a threat or capture
until white is completely winning
i this is ringing a bell you're
threatening e5 so the line actually
flows really nicely
and again you can watch the the video on
youtube for review but uh
the line usually like uh or black takes
you take a take
and after the trade you're hitting the
rook
there's rook b8
and then white keeps initiative by
taking the pawn which hits the bishop
three times this is the tactic and then
there's like a trick here because you
think like bishop takes g3 yeah and then
there's a very important move here
this move matters a lot um which is um
i knew no i studied this i studied this
oh god was it bishop takes
okay
let me think one second
um oh god i'm panicking yeah this is
still the carlson game so carlson had
this as white
um okay
what was it
it's good to see that you've definitely
studied this before
wait no i was thinking it's like this
this this
ah okay so the this idea can be like
completely winning in different types of
positions but fisheries seven just
doesn't work here yeah i need to just
i'm still remembering from memory which
is bad i need to just think because i
mean like if we just address this
position normally
i mean if we take right away it's not
that good because he takes here
um and he gets the pawn but i i do know
yeah you don't want to overthink this
too much
okay so it's just takes
so
this is what magnus carlsen played good
job there was a better move it takes g3
very it's like the most natural simple
move in the position there's a position
where it's like there's i'll explain
because this position
i have an improvement over magnus carl
yeah i remember this this is why i'm so
angsty because i remember you
specifically we looked at this and
you're like i found this crazy line that
magnus missed and i was like oh my god
that was so cool and i forgot it but the
the thing is my improvement it's only
very subtle and it's likely to transpose
back into the carlson game the
improvement is just to create an
opportunity where black can blunder
my improvement is queen dix queen
you will allow bishop takes f2
it looks like okay the like black can um
c6
is c6 yeah so after after
rook takes queen c6 and white is uh much
much better here
there's knight d5 but there's going to
be some like rook t1 and c4 and you're
you're holding on to the c6 pawn
so
what's likely to happen is
after rook takes d8
then you take back and then this is
going to be a transposition
i studied this
position
yeah so
when you take back you're hitting h7 and
you're still up upon like black hasn't
recaptured yet
so the most common move here is what
uh bose yochich plays against magnus is
f5
and now it's white to move
and now
c6
c6 yeah and uh it's a brilliant like
in-between move because you don't move
your bishop you just make a stronger
threat
and black is suffering
and why it's something here
there's knight d5 but after
um
it takes and takes into account
i think this is still the magnus game
and
yeah after rook rooks got traded you
have 95 and
dominating
beautiful
i just got really excited when you
brought this up it feels like when
you're like okay i don't read books you
know let's say it's like rekindling with
something like a cool artwork that you
saw years ago it's
yeah you see the mona lisa once but you
can see it again okay yeah that's a
that's much a much more intellectual
analogy than i was gonna be like guys
like when you know the end of a movie
and you don't want to spoil it to your
friends but you know mona lisa works too
that's a good one too it's good to
remember the spoilers
okay question i know i see this last
time and it's still a problem
um and maybe you answered it but it's
still a problem i hate this queen c7
stuff
so queen c7 is not powerful in this
position it's only annoying when the
knight is still back on b8 and the
knight usually goes to d7
this position you just win a pawn
oh yeah okay
what about
what about aha here
but this i might just take you down
another long tangent so you can just
yeah um i'll give you just a very quick
uh simple response
yeah you when when you see queen c7 you
take the palm
really
it looks wrong
uh queen but
you you force a queen to take back
okay
uh and then you continue development
like normal and your plan is to go for
e4
as long as you know this e4 idea it
gives white some nice initiative you're
going to have a slightly in development
um there's also a slight trap here if
black plays knight c6
uh then it's really awkward with queen
and bishop and you're winning material
knight b3
okay
got it this is all i needed just like a
quick like what would you do yeah most
players will castle play bishop d3 go
for e4
and
yeah you're you're not worse
okay awesome
perfect
so there's maybe one more like small
trick i can show you
yeah based off the game that we just
played
okay and it's a game
i don't know if you want to download
this pgn because i'm going to load in
like a very short video
okay so
maybe we can end with this like really
cool miniature
because it's
it's a 12 move game
and it features some just really
creative play from white in a
a london line that we actually just had
uh we had the first
[Music]
or actually
we had something similar um
i guess we had this position without c5
and c3 included yeah
um the concept will still remain the
same
so
in this position
or in the game that i'm about to show
you
there's a really cool move that you
usually don't get to play but it's queen
g4
i don't know if this rings any bells but
yes and it it deeply upset me
it's nice but it's so hard for me to
remember how to play
yeah it's only like this specific move
order black blaze knight f6 we have to
remember this i'm going to put it in my
chest base okay
an easier
line if if you want to like relieve the
tension first you can take and then play
queen g4
but um
the game i'll show you
yeah uh white gets in this queen g4 idea
and the play that follows is just
it's breathtaking
so you're hitting
d7
and black already has to make some
concession
defend the pawn oops um
sorry
oh i'm sorry um you could play queen g4
immediately what happened in the game uh
was takes first and then queen g4
oh
okay
so i will put that i'm mixing up the
move order too but uh it's tricky
the concept is still insane
uh yeah so black has to either play g6
or king f8 or queen f8
all of these moves make concessions if
either piece to f8 it's it's kind of
ugly
and if g6 it's a bit weakening to the
dark squares so in this game king f8 was
played
yep
uh white continued
knight d2
b6
f3 looks uh somewhat normal so far
and black went for this idea to trade
off the bishops so it's a very obscure
line and it's not worth like memorizing
the specific lines just kind of admiring
how white wins this position
is after take or after
95 first
improving the knight
f6
this is where the magic begins to happen
uh white does not move the knight
but plays a really kind of uh
artistic move is queen of four
nice defending light by pinning the pawn
but also aligning with the queen
so of course white is threatening what
move
uh knight
g6
and
yeah black has to defend so black plays
king f8
now white plays another really cool move
because now it looks like white's in a
little bit of trouble because uh
the knight is
pseudo pinned to the queen
um
but instead of moving the knight
white plays queen g3
hitting
e7
wow
uh so black plays queen c7
keeping the tension on diagonal and
defending the pawn
as far as i know uh white played one
more move and black resigned
and the next move is just uh it's such a
rare tactical idea
but hopefully you can find it or maybe
someone into a chat can find it
okay now i now i have to find it let's
see
um
bang
bang bang
oh
i think i got it i got it i got it it's
this
yeah knight g6
so normally
like this wouldn't work but you're
taking advantage of the job
is you hit the queen
black doesn't have time to take the
knight and when the queen trades
then you take back
unleashing the rook to pin the h-pawn
and black's rook is just trapped which
is nice
this is some good stuff
um yeah super rare tactic but uh this
did happen in a game
uh playing white was grand master bauer
so rated over 2600
and black was rated almost 2 300 feet
day
i'll save this to my model games oh sag
it's not on
it's not on chess base
for online games but i'll find it
i guess i can just
copy and paste it it was in 2014 um
i could just load in the clean pg
it's okay i'll i'll put it in no worries
okay
maybe anyway hopefully that gives you
some inspiration yeah yeah and i will
actually yeah we don't need to go over
the other move order um but i will
review because i actually remember
and also what is your youtube video
that's oh yeah so listen if if you just
search on youtube
frozen botez london it's the first two
results
there was one nine months ago and one 11
months ago
wait what was were they the same oh
oh wait we had two like we had two
london yeah this is our third london
lesson we've had so many london lessons
and i'm still trash
but you're you're improving every time
it's interesting to like see the
progress from lessons that's true
because when i showed you some of these
lines the first time like they were
brand new but now like you you have some
knowledge of them existing you just have
to
i'll take that i understand them oh this
is awesome i will link these in chat
okay i did not know that or this is so
great awesome okay chad i'm going to
share with you guys as well this i'm
going to give them my thumbs up
and come back to these because i know
like that queen line is in in in here so
i won't make you go over it since i have
the resources and i'm not gonna do what
hammer what alex did to hammer where
he gave her all his notes and then she
just never used the notes and she kept
asking him so i'm gonna use my notes
teacher
yeah sounds good and if you have like
just one-off questions like you play a
game or you want some recommendation
against the line just feel free to reach
out i'm even happy to have like a mini
like five-minute lesson if if you ever
like
uh you encounter something you don't
know so sounds awesome you're the best
eric
thank you so much one question are you
playing any like rated tournaments
coming up any any plans to make a
comeback to like raided otb chess
that's a good question i was it was
really sad i was training and preparing
for a tournament in december
um before boates abroad and it was my
last like opportunity to play um north
american junior because i was making the
limit and i could have had really good
chances at women feed a master um and
then i had to do college apps which were
due at the end of
um
june at the at the end of december
so i didn't do it yeah so i kind of
sacrificed getting a title for
potentially getting into schools which
i'm not going to get into so now i have
to rethink my plan but maybe in a couple
months i would really like to like
stream the whole experience instead of
doing a chess travel show maybe do it
where we're training
um but we have to figure out how to
integrate it into content because it's
just hard taking time off to compete for
chess right now it is tough also like
competing and trying to do content on
the side i tried to do it yeah uh last
month and it's it's very difficult but
how did it go
uh it was it was very refreshing to like
just play otb chess i played in
gibraltar it was like the battle of the
sexes oh
oh alex and i went but we weren't good
enough to qualify but we wanted to play
in that i think yeah they're i'm sure
usually it's like a big open tournament
uh so there might be opportunities to
play next year it was yeah exactly we
know we knew it was open but it wasn't
this year because yeah
it was super fun like super well
organized and uh i i got to play the
london a couple games and preparation
worked out that's awesome um i'm still
recapping my videos on on youtube but uh
yeah i'm looking at that right now how
oh so you were just yeah you're you're
just posting did you vlog the trip at
all
so i
i was doing recap videos like after
every game for the first half of the
tournament but then i just got dreamed
and
uh i i was preparing like four or five
hours before every game
like with opening preparation so i had
no time to like actually to content
exactly
that's why like yeah
that that is really the hardest thing
because if you want to make good con
like if you i mean you could just you
know not be as committed to the
tournament and do half priorities but
like no real chess player would want to
do that and it's just if you actually
want to do well you have to dedicate
every waking moment to preparing for the
games and it's so hard to feel like you
know you can prioritize other stuff
yeah it's it's maybe still doable but uh
yeah priorities are like it's it's
tricky to keep a balance and i'm playing
uh reykjavik open next month
and then
and then the national open in vegas in
june so
um
like
keep trying to find the best ways to
play and do content that's awesome i'm
so happy to hear yeah i know like levy
did one tournament but i feel like yeah
people give up on this so i really hope
i mean it is exhausting so don't like
you know put too much pressure on
yourself but these game analysis i saw
your pia crumbling that's really cool
that you're doing that that's awesome
that's a fun one too yeah i appreciate
that so
it's motivational and inspiring one day
me too chat maybe we'll go to vegas
i could play the vegas one that one's
like a big money it's like a big chess
festival so i'm actually looking forward
to that one because there's going to be
a bunch of side events so i might not
play the whole thing or play the main
event but they're like there's blitz and
i might give a slider there so
that suit oh you're gonna do a simul oh
i'll i'll look into that one
is it vegas open
vegaschessfestival.com
okay i will look into that yeah they i
mean i went there last year and there
was very good turnout and it's it's well
organized it's in vegas too so
awesome well i hope you the best of luck
thanks so much
millions of subs your videos are great i
will be studying that london thank you
for for preparing and taking the time to
train me i really appreciate it it's a
pleasure yeah all the best if you have
questions feel free to reach out and uh
yeah we'll be in touch
thank you eric let me just before i
leave there we go okay
have a good one eric thank you andrea
take care